[Music]
couples that get sick together stay
together
we just had our year anniversary that's
very cute Amy Schumer's stopped by Ellen
Monday and opened up about her not so
romantic trip to Paris with boyfriend
Ben Hanna's neither of us have ever been
to France because we're both trash right
and so we were like let's go and so we
go and it's it was like you know we want
to be romantic but the lovers getaway
took a turn for the worst when they got
food poisoning and couldn't hide the
gross side-effects back at the hotel and
I knew it was over I'm yelling at him
like it was so great dating you I wish
you the best luck you're gonna meet the
greatest girl you know but I knew I knew
it was over the silver lining Amy said
she learned one valuable lesson and that
is when I learned not to ever throw up
in a wicker the 35 year old had to be
hospitalized and naturally documented it
on Instagram but all's well that ends
well three months later these lovebirds
are still going strong
you